Dr Peterson's.
Thank you.
First of all,
it's great pleasure being here.
It's awesome to see you live.
Um,
I basically got into your wicks just earlier this year and I had an original
question,
but your talk today kind of made me decide to change my mind.
I'm always going to ask.
Um,
do you feel as though would you agree with me and the sentiment that the left
has pushed so hard for total control of our society over the last however many
years?
It's almost to a point,
we're saying 2013 was a different time.
Um,
would you say that because they pushed so hard,
they've created this backlash and the backlash created,
caused them to backlash back again.
So they doubled down with their ideology and then they get,
they lose another argument,
they lose another ideological war.
They news losing other me more and they doubled down and doubled down again and
again.
And they still can't seem to meme,
they can't seem to argue.
They can't seem,
they can't,
they don't want to have an intellectual discussion.
And as an as an interpretation of what you were saying,
there is no,
there doesn't seem to be any,
any,
any care of what's right with them.
They just want power.
They just want,
they just want to win.
Um,
do you,
would you agree with the sentiment that they're burning themselves out and
creating the mass red pilling of the,
uh,
conservative movement that we see going on?
Would you possibly think that maybe they've committed suicide and,
and talks like this,
people like yourself,
Ben Shapiro and others who talk to people like what the subjects that we do the
taboo of nowadays?
Um,
possibly that this,
this is the answer to defeat the,
the leftist stranglehold.
It's on our society.
Let,
will untangle some of that.
Okay.
So first of all,
well first of all,
the first observation is a really interesting one because you know that things
can go out of hand very,
very rapidly.
Yeah.
And the reason they do that is because of positive feedback loops.
Now the thing that Kurzweil talks about is a positive feedback loop and
intelligent machine makes another intelligent machine that makes another
intelligent machine.
And that's a positive feedback loop and that can spiral upwards out of control
very rapidly.
And that's what polarization is.
It's like I tap you,
you tap me,
I slap you,
you punch me well up and goes well.
I think that's partly why in the New Testament,
for example,
there's an injunction that says turn the other cheek,
resist not evil.
Why?
Because otherwise you get into a positive feedback loop and then you better look
the hell out and things can tilt very,
very rapidly.
I mean,
all you have to do,
look at what happened in World War one new unexpected that it was like one,
one relatively minor member,
I think of the aristocracy,
if I remember was assassinated in one minor little country.
It's like bang,
everything fell apart.
And that's positive feedback loops,
right?
And so that's what we're in right now and we've got to be,
and that's a really chaotic time.
And so I would say maintain self control and don't aim to win.
Amen.
Peace.
Because winning,
that's,
that's not peace.
It's better to aim for peace.
You know,
I've got this talk coming up in November 11th I'm quite worried about it because
I know there's going to be protesters there and that they've been emboldened by
the fact that they shut the torque down before and I want to make a video I'll
probably do tomorrow telling everyone that comes to that meeting to like watch
their bloody step and stay out of the gutter because you just,
we're at,
we're at a point now where under the wrong circumstances,
if the wrong person does the wrong thing,
that the consequences will be very great.
Now we can't predict which action is going to precipitate that and or even if
that will happen,
but it's chaotic enough so that it could happen.
So you know,
also govern yourselves accordingly.
Now the problem is is that there are people who would be happy if there was
blood running in the street.
They're the same sort of people that shoot up high schools or kill innocent,
you know,
elementary school kids just to show what they're made of and what they believe.
And that's a big problem.
But for the rest of us,
like hopefully calmer heads can prevail.
And so it really is important not to win.
It's like fighting with your wife.
You don't win.
You can't because you have to live with her because you can't win.
But maybe you can solve the problem and bring about peace.
And so you've got a practice doing that practice restraint.
And remember too that these people that you're talking about who had radical
leftists is most of the time,
they're not like they're 95% like you.
And if you pull them out of the mob,
they're just like your,
your neighbor's 19 year old kid who's kind of clueless and rebellious.
Right.
And who you might even like you put them in the mob.
It's a whole different thing.
And so you got to remember that too.
Oh,
the fear of social isolation,
you say no,
it's just that they're possessed by these ideas,
but,
but only partially,
you know,
you hardly find it full blooded.
Absolutely committed radical leftist activist.
You know,
like there are some,
but not very many.
Most of it.
It's just fragmentary behavior.
And you have to remember that like when the students come out to protest me,
it was a case,
particularly at McMaster,
I have to remember these kids,
they're not much different than my kids.
They are when they're in a stupid mob behind a hammer and sickle flag,
you know,
but,
but
you don't want to make a low resolution,
homogenous representation of them.
And so,
and so you,
that's why again,
I think instead of winning,
you turn to your own development.
You turn to your own development,
you do what you can to stop doing the things that you're doing that aren't good
because you're not going to hurt anybody.
If you do that,
all you're going to do is help.
And otherwise you'll participate in this polarization.
And that's unless you want that.
And you know,
there's a dark part of people that it's part of the part that voted for Trump
would like to burn things to the ground.
It's like to help,
I know how people felt when they went into the voting booth.
It was like Hillary,
Hillary dealt with it.
Trump,
you know?
And that's,
that's a hell of a thing to say to hell with it,
you know?
Although I could,
I could certainly understand that sentiment.
So we have to be careful.
And all of you people who are here,
who are advocates of free speech and who are theoretically happy to come hear me
speak,
it's like,
I really do believe it.
I truly believe this.
And this is something I learned in part from social knits and in part from you.
I missed that the way that you set the world straight is by constraining the
malevolence in your own heart.
And that's no joke,
man.
That's no easy thing.
And that's a good voyage for people to go on if they want something difficult
and worthwhile to do.
So.